you know the last week or so I've been
thinking to some degree it seems as
though so-called wokeness is actually
the prevailing opinion in a way it seems
as the wokeness is winning in the United
States and Eugene Robinson from The
Washington Post wrote a really great
piece yesterday called wokeness is
winning and it makes some excellent
points backed by facts which I'm going
to get to in a moment but when I started
to suspect that this entire anti-woke
Framing and campaign and Obsession from
the right maybe a bit of an overplay of
the hand that they are uh that they are
currently playing was polling out of
Florida
that a lot of Ron desantis's extreme
anti-woke stuff could potentially
backfire because by and large a majority
of the country seems to sympathize with
the woke perspectives even when defined
as woke now there's two different things
here okay let me give you an analogy
when we talk about health care
you could say the government has a duty
to provide a basic level of care to
everybody regardless of ability to pay
very high support for that claim on the
other hand if you say there should be a
government takeover of your health care
very low support for that claim but
when we actually dissect what do we mean
here and accurately represent what
things are we see that people generally
tend to agree more than they disagree
with the left-wing perspective on Health
Care the government does have a basic
duty to provide an entry level of care
at minimum to everybody if you say to
people are you in favor of wokeness
versus if you say Do you think that it's
important to promote equality of
opportunity and accept people who are
trans and businesses should take steps
to promote diversity when you ask people
about those individual issues there is
significant support for them but then
you go well what about woke are you woke
much lower level of support
case in point in Eugene Robinson's piece
in the Washington Post
he talks about a survey that was
conducted by the nonpartisan Research
Institute norc at the University of
Chicago they do a lot of different
opinion polling and we often cite them
on the show
they looked at actual so-called woke
issues and found that the woke side of
the equation is way more popular than
you might think based on what you see on
Fox news or elsewhere on the issue of
quote accepting people who are
transgender
56 percent of respondents said either
Society has been about right or hasn't
gone far enough when it comes to
accepting people who are trans the woke
positions are a majority the minority
thinks that acceptance of trans people
has gone too far another example on the
issue of promoting equality between men
and women
86 percent of respondents say that
Society is either where it should be or
hasn't gone far enough to promote
equality between men and women that's a
woke country
by their term now of course woke as a
pejorative is used to criticize these
positions but the point here is when you
ask people about their views on issues
they very much are in favor unquote
accepting people who are gay lesbian or
bisexual the poll found that 69 percent
of respondents believe that Society has
been well calibrated on promoting
acceptance or has not gone far enough
that is very woke and then lastly on
businesses taking steps to promote
racial and ethnic diversity woke beats
anti-woke 70 to 28 even when you ask
about schools and universities taking
steps to promote racial and ethnic
diversity again wokeness wins 67 to 30.
last aspect to this specifically about
schools in the context of banning drag
shows and banning books and all of it
when respondents were asked
which of these concerns you more about
schools today given the choice of two
statements are you more concerned about
schools Banning books and censoring
topics of educational importance or are
you more concerned about uh um are you
in favor of uh schools doing that and
concerned that inappropriate things may
be taught to your kids by an almost two
to one margin
people are more concerned about the
Banning of books and the limiting of
teaching in schools rather than oh my
kid might be taught something
inappropriate so there's a couple of
important takeaways from this number one
as another reminder Reddit and Twitter
aren't real life in the sense that ideas
can be over or underrepresented in those
spheres
and when you actually talk to people
just out there you get dramatically
different results and number two
even the concerted effort of how has it
been a year has it been two years three
years it's kind of all the time work but
certainly we've seen one to three years
of a concerted effort to go after a lot
of these same elements
despite all of that it hasn't been that
effective at actually convincing people
to take so-called anti-woke positions
which I would call in many cases just
anti-science positions and so for
someone like Iran DeSantis who's about
Florida is where woke comes to die and
on and on and on it may help him in the
Republican primary in some states not
necessarily even all but it may not be
super useful nationally if he were to
win the nomination Ron DeSantis that is
in running against the eventual
Democratic nominee because it still
seems that even after a blitz of one to
three years just attacking these views
in these positions most Americans
actually come down on what is often
characterized as the woke position
will be an interesting thing to see in
24 when it comes to strategy
as many of my viewers and listeners of
course know I have many family members
who work in the field of mental health
and I think one of the most important
things that we can do is to both
increase access and reduce stigma when
it comes to Mental Health Services and
that's why I am thrilled that one of our
sponsors today is better help better
help is the world's largest therapy
service and it is 100 online with better
help you can tap into a network of over
000 licensed and experienced therapists
an important word therapists who can
help you with a wide range of issues you
answer a few questions about your needs
and your preferences and better help
will match you with a therapist that
meets your needs you can then talk to
your therapist however you feel
comfortable could be text could be chat
phone video call you can message your
therapist anytime you can schedule live
sessions when it's convenient and if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but it's on your
schedule
and it's at a more affordable price get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below